Les dije tres cosas el año pasado.
Les dije que las estadísticas del mundo
no han sido propiamente liberadas.
Debido a eso, aún tenemos la vieja idea
de países en desarrollo y países industrializados, y esto es incorrecto.
Y que los gráficos animados pueden crear una diferencia.
Las cosas están cambiando.
Y hoy, en la página Web de la división de estadística de la ONU,
dice que para el primero de mayo habrá acceso total a las bases de datos.
(Aplausos)
Y si puedo compartir con ustedes esta imagen en pantalla,
tres cosas han ocurrido.
La ONU abrió sus bases de datos estadísticas,
y tenemos una nueva versión del software
funcionando en gapminder.org en la red,
así que ya no tienen que descargarlo.
Déjenme repetir lo que vieron el año pasado.
Las burbujas son países.
Aquí tienen la tasa de fertilidad -- el número de niños por mujer --
y aquí tienen la esperanza de vida en años.
Esto es 1950 -- estos eran los países industrializados,
esos eran los países en desarrollo.
En esa época había un "nosotros" y un "ellos".
Había una gran diferencia en el mundo.
Pero entonces cambió, y continuó bastante bien.
Y esto es lo que ocurre.
Pueden ver cómo China es la gran burbuja roja;
la azul es India.
Voy a intentar ser
un poco más serio este año al mostrarles
cómo han cambiado las cosas.
Y es África la que sobresale aquí como el problema, ¿no es así?
Las familias todavía numerosas y la epidemia de VIH
bajaron a los países de esta forma.
Esto es más o menos lo que vimos el año pasado,
y así es como continuará en el futuro.
Y continuaré diciendo, ¿es esto posible?
Porque vean ahora, presenté estadísticas que no existen.
Porque aquí es donde estamos.
¿Será posible que esto ocurra?
Estoy cubriendo mi tiempo de vida aquí, ¿saben?
Espero vivir 100 años.
Y aquí es donde estamos hoy.
Ahora, ¿podemos cambiar a ver aquí la situación económica del mundo?
Quisiera mostrar eso en contraste con la supervivencia infantil.
Cambiaremos los ejes:
aquí tienen la mortalidad infantil -- esto es, supervivencia --
cuatro niños mueren aquí, 200 mueren ahí.
Y este es el PIB per cápita en éste eje.
Esto fue en el 2007.
Y si retrocedemos en el tiempo, he agregado estadísticas históricas --
aquí vamos, aquí vamos, aquí vamos -- no hay muchos datos de hace 100 años.
Algunos países todavía tienen registros.
Estamos buscando en el archivo,
y cuando llegamos a 1820,
solamente Austria y Suecia pueden producir números.
(Risas)
Pero estaban aquí abajo, tenían 1,000 dólares por persona por año.
Y perdían un quinto de sus niños antes de su primer cumpleaños.
Esto es lo que pasa en todo el mundo, si reproducimos todo el mundo,
cómo se volvieron lentamente más ricos,
y fueron agregando datos.
¿No es hermoso cuando se obtienen datos?
¿Ven la importancia de eso?
Aquí, los niños no viven más tiempo.
El siglo pasado, 1870, fue malo para los niños en Europa,
porque la mayoría de estos datos son de Europa.
Fue solo a partir del nuevo siglo
que más del 90% de los niños sobrevivieron su primer año.
Esto es India llegando, con los primeros datos de India.
Y éstos son los Estados Unidos alejándose, ganando más dinero.
Y pronto veremos a China apareciendo por la esquina del fondo.
Y sube con Mao Tse-Tsung consiguiendo salud,
sin volverse rico.
Aquí muere, y Deng Xiaoping trae dinero,
y se mueve hacia acá.
Y las burbujas continúan moviéndose ahí,
y así es como se ve el mundo hoy.
(Aplausos)
Echemos un vistazo a los Estados Unidos.
Tenemos una función aquí -- puedo decirle al mundo "quédate donde estás".
Y tomo a los Estados Unidos -- aún podemos ver el fondo --
los pongo encima así, y ahora retrocedemos.
Y podemos ver que los Estados Unidos
se van a la derecha de la tendencia.
Siempre están del lado del dinero.
Y en 1915, Estados Unidos era un vecino de la India --
la India presente, contemporánea.
Esto significa que los Estados Unidos eran más ricos,
pero perdían proporcionalmente más niños que India hoy.
Y miren esto -- comparen con las Filipinas de hoy.
Filipinas tiene hoy casi la misma economía
que los Estados Unidos en la Primer Guerra Mundial.
Pero tenemos que adelantar bastante a los Estados Unidos
para encontrar el mismo índice de salud
que tenemos en Filipinas.
Cerca de 1957, la salud de los Estados Unidos
es igual que la de Filipinas.
Y éste es el drama de este mundo, que muchos llaman globalizado,
que Asia, los países Árabes, América Latina,
están mucho más avanzados en salud, educación,
y en cantidad de recursos humanos, que en economía.
Hay discrepancia sobre lo que ocurre hoy
en las economías emergentes.
Ahí, ahora, los beneficios sociales, el progreso social,
van por delante del progreso económico.
En 1957 -- Estados Unidos tenía la misma economía que Chile tiene hoy.
¿Y cuánto falta para que Estados Unidos
tenga la misma salud que Chile tiene hoy?
Creo que tenemos que avanzar, aquí -- en 2001 o 2002 --
Estados Unidos tiene la misma salud que Chile.
¡Chile los está alcanzando!
Dentro de un par de años Chile puede tener mejor supervivencia infantil
que los Estados Unidos.
Esto realmente es un cambio, este intervalo
de más o menos 30 o 40 años de diferencia en salud.
Y detrás de la salud está el nivel de educación.
Y mucha infraestructura
y recursos humanos generales que están ahí.
Ahora, podemos quitar esto --
y quisiera mostrarles la tasa de velocidad,
el ritmo de cambio, cómo de rápido se mueven.
Regresemos a 1920, y quiero ver Japón.
Y quiero ver Suecia y los Estados Unidos.
Y voy a organizar una carrera aquí
entre este Ford amarillento aquí
este Toyota rojo ahí,
y el Volvo café.
(Risas)
Y aquí vamos, aquí vamos.
El Toyota tuvo un muy mal comienzo, como pueden ver,
y el Ford Estadounidense se salió de la pista aquí.
Al Volvo le está yendo bastante bien.
Esta es la guerra. El Toyota se despistó, y ahora
el Toyota viene por el lado más saludable de Suecia --
¿Lo pueden ver?
Y están sobrepasando a Suecia,
y ahora son más saludables que Suecia.
Y esta es la parte en la que vendí el Volvo y compré el Toyota.
(Risas)
Ahora podemos ver que el ritmo de cambio fue enorme en Japón.
Realmente los alcanzaron.
Y esto cambia gradualmente.
Tenemos que ver a través de generaciones para entenderlo.
Déjenme mostrarles algo así como mi historia familiar --
hicimos estas gráficas de aquí.
Y esto es lo mismo, el dinero aquí, y la salud, ¿saben?
Y esta es mi familia.
Esto es Suecia, 1830, cuando mi tatarabuela nació.
Suecia era como Sierra Leona de hoy.
Y aquí es cuando la bisabuela nació, 1863.
Y Suecia era como Mozambique.
Y aquí es cuando mi abuela nació, 1891.
Ella me cuidó de niño,
así que no estoy hablando de estadística --
ahora es la historia de mi familia.
Así es cuando creo en las estadísticas,
cuando son estadísticas verificadas por la abuela.
(Risas)
Creo que es la mejor manera de verificar datos históricos.
Suecia era como Ghana.
Es interesante ver la enorme diversidad
dentro del África subsahariana.
Les dije el año pasado, les digo de nuevo,
mi madre nació en Egipto, y yo -- ¿Quién soy yo?
Soy el Mexicano de la familia.
Y mi hija, ella nació en Chile,
y la nieta nació en Singapur,
la nación más sana del planeta Tierra.
Sobrepasó a Suecia hace dos o tres años,
con mejor supervivencia infantil.
Pero son muy pequeños, ¿saben?
Están tan cerca del hospital que nunca podremos
ganarles en estos bosques
(Risas)
Pero en homenaje a Singapur.
Singapur son los mejores ahora.
Esto también parece ser ahora una muy buena historia.
Pero no es tan sencillo, puede que no todo sea una buena historia.
Porque tengo que mostrarles otra de las habilidades:
Podemos hacer que este color represente la variable --
¿Qué escojo aquí?
Emisión de Dióxido de Carbono, tonelada per cápita.
En 1962, los Estados Unidos emitían 16 toneladas por persona.
China emitía 0.6,
y la India emitía 0.32 toneladas per cápita.
¿Qué ocurre cuando progresamos?
Bien, ven la bonita historia de volverse más ricos
y más sanos --
todos lo hicieron a base de la emisión de dióxido de carbono.
Nadie lo ha logrado hasta ahora.
Y no tenemos los datos actualizados
de aquí en delante, porque son datos muy controvertidos.
Y aquí estamos. 2001.
Y en la discusión que atendí con líderes globales,
muchos dicen que el problema de las economías emergentes,
liberan demasiado dióxido de carbono.
Y el Ministro de Medio Ambiente de India dice,
"Bien, ustedes son los que causaron el problema.
Los países de la OCDE -- los países de altos ingresos --
ellos fueron los que causaron el cambio climático.
Pero les perdonamos, porque no lo sabían.
Pero de ahora en delante, contamos per cápita.
De ahora en delante contamos per cápita.
Y todos son responsables por las emisiones per cápita".
Esto realmente demuestra que no hemos visto un buen progreso
económico y de salud en el mundo
sin destruir el clima.
Y esto es realmente lo que tiene que cambiar.
He sido criticado por mostrarles una imagen muy positiva del mundo,
pero no creo que sea así.
El mundo es un lugar bastante sucio.
Esto es lo que llamamos la Calle del Dólar.
Todos viven en esta calle.
Lo que ganan -- en qué numero viven --
es cuánto ganan por día.
Esta familia gana cerca de un dólar al día.
Avanzamos por la calle
y encontramos una familia que gana de dos a tres dólares diarios.
Y avanzamos aquí -- encontramos el primer jardín de la calle,
y ellos ganan de 10 a 50 dólares diarios.
¿Cómo viven?
Si vemos la cama aquí, podemos ver
que duermen en un tapete en el suelo.
Esto es lo que la línea de pobreza es --
el 80% del ingreso es exclusivamente para satisfacer necesidades energéticas
la comida del día.
Esto es de dos a cinco dólares, tienes una cama.
Y aquí pueden ver un cuarto mucho mejor.
Expuse esto para Ikea, y querían ver
el sofá inmediatamente.
(Risas)
Y éste es el sofá, cómo va surgiendo de ahí.
Y lo interesante, cuando van alrededor en esta foto panorámica,
es ver que la familia aún está sentada en el suelo,
aunque hay un sofá.
Si miran hacia la cocina, pueden ver que
la gran diferencia para las mujeres no viene de entre uno o 10 dólares.
Viene de más allá, cuando realmente pueden obtener
buenas condiciones de trabajo en la familia.
Y si realmente quieren ver la diferencia,
pueden ver el baño aquí.
Esto puede cambiar, puede cambiar.
Todas son fotografías e imágenes de África,
y puede volverse mucho mejor.
Podemos salir de la pobreza.
Mis investigaciones no han sido en informática o algo así.
Pasé 20 años entrevistando a granjeros africanos
que estaban en el borde de la hambruna.
Y este es el resultado de la investigación de sus necesidades.
Lo bueno aquí es que no pueden ver
quiénes son los investigadores en esta fotografía.
Es cuando la investigación funciona para las sociedades --
realmente deben vivir con la gente.
Cuando están en la pobreza, todo es acerca de la supervivencia.
Es acerca de tener comida.
Y estas dos jóvenes granjeras, que son niñas aún --
porque los padres murieron de VIH y SIDA --
ellas están discutiendo con un agrónomo entrenado.
Él es uno de los mejores agrónomos de Malawi, Junatambe Kumbira,
y están discutiendo qué tipo de yuca plantarán --
la mejor convertidora de luz a alimento que el hombre ha encontrado.
Y están muy, muy interesadas en recibir consejos,
porque son para sobrevivir en la pobreza.
Ése es un contexto.
Salir de la pobreza.
Las mujeres nos dijeron una cosa: " Dénos tecnología.
Odiamos este mortero, estar de pie horas y horas.
Dénos un molino para que podamos moler harina,
entonces podremos pagar lo demás nosotras".
La tecnología las sacará de la pobreza,
pero se necesita un mercado para salir de ella.
Y esta mujer está muy feliz ahora, llevando sus productos al mercado.
Pero está muy agradecida por la inversión pública en escuelas
por poder contar y que no la engañen en el mercado.
Quiere que su hijo esté sano, para poder ir al mercado
y no tener que quedarse en casa.
Y quiere la infraestructura -- es cómodo tener un camino pavimentado.
También hay cosas buenas con el crédito.
Micro-créditos le dieron la bicicleta, ¿saben?
Y la información le dirá cuándo ir al mercado con qué producto.
Pueden hacer esto.
Mi experiencia con 20 años en África es que
lo aparentemente imposible es posible.
África no lo ha hecho mal.
En 50 años han ido de una situación pre-medieval
a una muy decente igual a Europa hace 100 años,
Con naciones y estados funcionales.
Diría que el África subsahariana ha sido la que mejor lo ha hecho
en los últimos 50 años.
Porque no consideramos de dónde vinieron.
Es éste estúpido concepto de países en desarrollo
que nos pone a nosotros, a Argentina y a Mozambique juntos hace 50 años,
y dice que Mozambique lo hizo peor.
Necesitamos saber un poco más del mundo.
Tengo un vecino que conoce 200 tipos de vino.
Lo sabe todo.
Conoce el nombre de la uva, temperatura y todo.
Yo solo conozco dos tipos de vino, tinto y blanco.
(Risas)
Pero mi vecino conoce dos tipos de países --
industrializados y en desarrollo.
Y yo conozco 200, conozco acerca de los datos pequeños.
Ustedes pueden hacer eso.
(Aplausos)
Pero tengo que actuar seriamente. ¿Cómo actuar seriamente?
Mostrando un PowerPoint, ¿saben?
(Risas)
Homenaje al paquete Office, ¿no?
¿Qué es esto, qué es esto, que estoy diciendo?
Les estoy diciendo que hay muchas dimensiones de desarrollo.
Todos quieren ver sus proyectos favoritos.
En el sector corporativo, quieren a los micro-créditos.
Si estás en una organización no gubernamental,
quieren igualdad de género.
O si eres un profesor, adorarás la UNESCO, y así.
A nivel global, necesitamos tener más que lo nuestro.
Necesitamos de todo.
Todas estas cosas son importantes para el desarrollo,
especialmente cuando acabas de salir de la pobreza
y deberías ir hacia el bienestar.
Ahora, en lo que debemos pensar
es: ¿qué es un objetivo para el desarrollo
y cuáles son los medios de desarrollo?
Déjenme evaluar cuáles son los medios mas importantes.
Crecimiento económico, para mí, como profesor de salud pública,
es lo más importante para el desarrollo,
porque explica el 80% de la supervivencia.
Gobierno. Tener un gobierno funcional -- es lo
que sacó a California de la miseria de 1850.
Fue el gobierno el que hizo que la ley funcionara finalmente.
La educación y los recursos humanos son importantes.
La salud también es importante, pero no tanto como promedio.
El medio ambiente es importante.
Los derechos humanos también son importantes, pero solo reciben un punto.
¿Y que hay de los objetivos? ¿Hacia donde vamos?
No nos interesa el dinero.
El dinero no es un objetivo.
Es el mejor medio, pero le doy cero como objetivo.
El Gobierno, es divertido votar en una elección,
pero no es objetivo.
Ir a la escuela, no es un objetivo, es un medio.
A la salud le doy dos puntos. Digo, es agradable estar sano
--especialmente a mi edad-- si puedes estar aquí, estás sano.
Y eso es bueno, recibe dos positivos.
El medio ambiente es muy, muy crucial.
No hay nada para el nieto si no lo preservas.
¿Pero cuáles son los objetivos importantes?
Por supuesto, son los derechos humanos.
Los derechos humanos son el objetivo,
pero no son un medio fuerte para lograr el desarrollo.
Y cultura. La cultura es lo más importante, diría yo,
porque es lo que trae alegría a la vida.
Ése es el valor de vivir.
Así que lo aparentemente imposible es posible.
Incluso los países africanos lo pueden lograr.
Y les he mostrado aquí que lo aparentemente imposible es posible.
Y recuerden, por favor recuerden mi mensaje principal,
que es: lo aparentemente imposible es posible.
Podemos tener un buen mundo.
Les mostré las fotos, lo probé en el PowerPoint.
y creo que les convenceré mediante la cultura.
(Risas)
(Aplausos)
¡Traigan mi espada!
Tragar sables viene de la India antigua.
Es una expresión cultural que por miles de años
ha inspirado a los seres humanos a pensar más allá de lo obvio.
(Risas)
Y les mostraré que lo aparentemente imposible es posible
al tomar esta pieza de acero -- acero sólido --
esta es la bayoneta de la armada Sueca, 1850,
del último año en que estuvimos en guerra.
Y todo es acero sólido, como pueden oír.
Y voy a tomar esta espada de acero,
y empujarla a través de mi cuerpo de carne y sangre,
y probarles que lo aparentemente imposible es posible.
¿Puedo pedir un momento de silencio absoluto?
(Aplausos)